so guys last night I saw the Maze Runner
I loved it actually it's it's it's
difficult when I do these movies and
don't like movie I actually love this
filming so much um I do have a few
questions when it came to the running
scenes how many takes did you have to do
in a row that just looked exhausting
yeah let me take how many take so the
rune scenes you guys did 16 someone was
funny yeah yeah 30 it seemed like I
would just have them CGI my legs I don't
know that would have been so good stay
still yeah like my legs remember that
about body work so like sundown yeah you
just wear green trousers take me sir
single just white green trousers yeah I
can't take you seriously we're in the my
own less legitimate 4002 now let's talk
about politics so in this film we see a
pack of over twenty boys coexist with
just one girl was this film also based
off my college parties oh I play up uh
your massively influenced by in college
yeah yeah we want to thank you for that
you're welcome no one else thank me that
yeah we had we had moonshine on um well
not remember we're drinking that but
that rock acts have been showing me a
little bit more party you have a lot of
fires at your party when we had a bit a
little bit of really far as I thought I
legitimately thought that was P by the
way when in the moonshine famous chicken
bowl that's it looked like that cuz
they're pranking they're like cats yeah
yeah I mean you're like
all over the place because you gagged at
first I'm like oh that was urine so
there's obviously a ton of CGI in this
film a lot of effects how difficult is
it to imagine massive robotic spiders
coming at you and how much did you have
to imagine in front of you we were
really lucky wasted so much stuff
beforehand you're kind of committed to
bringing this world to life before we'd
even start shooting so he had a lot
concept art he had summer
what was it called that thing that he
played us previous previous um so we
could actually really know what he was
thinking and and it's kind of fun to be
able to use your own imagination you
just picture whatever scares you
personally the most which was that for
you I'm like slime and stuff which ended
up being pretty similar there's a lot of
slime there yeah that's what I kept
thinking that's yeah boys nothing he's a
great slime as well more like very
smelly and dirty is she gonna put up my
mouth yeah you know that's ten like
seven yeah
we're just kinda gross fur and like we
were covered in dirt pretty much the
entire time and we had this like makeup
situation when they'd add and it got so
Sejal you didn't even mean it I'm coming
you shot in New Orleans you guys were
already sweating as is so yeah comes
done bathing at some point yeah yeah
okay well it's for the film it's its
commitment honestly like it's just its
cleanest I would not be bathed anyway
want to sleep you can shower you could
shower get clean and then you come into
work and you just get covered in yes
justice i comment and they careful
skills things yeah yeah just like it's
okay so Mike okay yeah easily after they
have showers in the glade no not a bad
character birthday so you guys had a
very young cast a lot of you late teens
early 20s is it fun to be working with
young people without any boring old
people around to take things down or
they don't stinky old guy knows think
you'll get it ruin the fun is a blast
we I think we all like you know can
agree or not we're just meeting to be
really embarrassing who's all just like
know we all hate we all literally just
had like he was like so being away at
summer camp you know like really look
you know exhausting like summer camp but
like at the end of every day no matter
how long the day you know we would
always hang out like there's I don't
even think there's one night where was
ladies like Niagara who's gonna hit the
bed like no matter is our process for
one bear yeah yeah a point of just
because we're so you know naturally
close yeah yeah you know so and we hit
it off so quick that will work it's a
really great film I hope it gets to do
more because I think it'd be really
great so yeah we also to my right this
was a blast thank you thank you guys
yeah this isn't that the head has not
been work at all
you